everybody so I memory burger I'm going
to be talking today about performance
matters this is joint work with my
former PhD student Charlie Curtsinger
I'm going to tell you a story that
happened a short time ago in a valley
far far away
not not actually this one but in fact
this one so the story is about character
who we're gonna call Luke Luke is our
hero of course is a hero in Silicon
Valley because Luke has an idea for an
app alright so here is luke's genius
idea for an app basically you use your
smartphone and you take pictures of
things and then it goes and finds
matches like and returns them to you and
he's got a great name for it as well
it's gonna call it a goal and he's
pretty sure ah --gel is gonna totally
disrupt image search nobody has told him
about google image search yet but anyway
so he sets about building it so he makes
the prototype on all right so the
prototype toggle works like this take a
picture it gets sent off to the Google
Google Data Center if it is new it gets
added to the database and then at the
same time it goes and finds similar
pictures and sends them back to the user
alright so this is pretty
straightforward you can kind of abstract
out this flow if you think of it as
follows you get a request the request
comes in it essentially spawns two
threads one of them goes and takes the
image and let's say compresses it and
then saves it to a three and a half inch
floppy as one does and then at the same
time it does some indexing to look up
matches right so it does a search after
doing some feature extraction and then
sends it back to the user via paper
airplane which is the most effective
method known to man and then eventually
these two threads join up alright so
this is obviously a simplification
I've alighted certain things like for
example locks so when you have locks
right there's some database for example
you can't be modifying the database
simultaneously blah blah blah but anyway
this is essentially at a high level how
angle is going to work so Luke goes and
ships it off to the app store it gets
approved and you know users start coming
and ah --gel is working right he's
disrupting image search but then as the
number of users kind of like mount it
turns out ogle starts getting slow right
so it takes a long time for oggela
though all right so this is too bad he's
not happy about this he's not really
sure what to do so but before we get
into that let me talk about another
version of Luke this is also Luke this
is the cool Cool Hand Luke if you will
with his glasses all right but really
this is Luke in the 80s all right so
he's got the 80s glasses to match and of
course those of you old enough to know
or who have watched TV know that there
were no smartphones in the 80s there
were instead computers with big CRTs so
this is what auga looked like in the 80s
so you'd have some ASCII art and you
want to go out and it would connect via
some modem let's say search through the
database this is version 1.0 of Augen a
4 and it comes up with its matches and
this is your user interface so hope you
liked it
all right now of course back in the day
1984 computers were really slow right
really slow and so actually this you
know Luke today who is like ah Ghilas
too slow what things were really bad in
1984 right but it turns out things were
also kind of better in a way so
performance used to be really easy so
I'm sure all of you have seen this kind
of graph what I'm going to show you is
on the left the number of transistors as
years progress on the x-axis if they go
up you'll notice it is a log scale and
on the right you have clock speed which
roughly corresponds to computing
performance and so basically for years
and years and years we had this
situation where the number of
transistors were increasing roughly at
doubling every 18 months
this is famously Moore's law and this
generally had the effect of allowing
clock speed to increase and so you had
smaller features this meant that your
programs would actually run faster and
in fact you could just literally wait
right if you buy new hardware in fact
the upgrade cycle every you know every
year or so like if you bought a new
computer everything would run much
faster right now things were slow right
so don't be so excited about how great
it was back that right
was bad right 33 megahertz 266 was
awesome back then and kind of terrible
today okay
but it did change the landscape of what
it meant to be somebody who works on
performance improvement because this is
what you would do right so you they're
really in a way was no sense trying to
squeeze out any performance out of
something when it was going to double in
eighteen months right the chance that
you in eighteen months were going to
squeeze out double the performance
pretty slender so you might as well just
sip mojitos on the beach all right I can
tell you that this was well maybe the
mojitos in beach part notwithstanding
this was actually kind of a strategy
that was recommended for high
performance computing people would
literally say we're just gonna upgrade
the computers next year or in two years
so focus on something else
don't focus on performance right now
unfortunately that's not the current
state of affairs right so today as all
of you know when you upgrade a computer
it does not get faster anymore maybe it
gets lighter maybe it has improved
battery life maybe not but but basically
what happened is eventually Moore's law
kind of ran out of steam the reason that
it did is not actually it's not actually
true that Moore's law ran out of steam
this is technically a problem called
Dennard scaling and so Dennard scaling
ran out and so route not right now we're
in a situation where basically if we
clock things up we no longer can
dissipate the heat on chips effectively
enough to make them run faster so
transistor counts actually are still
increasing which is why we have multiple
cores so we have a bunch of transistors
what are we going to do with them let's
just stamp out more of the same thing
right so that's great but it's also not
super awesome because if you have a
program that is not parallel it's not
going to run any faster so everything
now has multi-core your your phone has
multi-core but it turns out it's still a
problem so these are actual screenshots
from App Store updates it's every App
Store update practically is about
performance or bug fixes and so here's
one that says
under the hood updates for better
performance as opposed to the over the
hood updates
okay here's bug fixes and performance
improvements bug fixes an important
performance improvements and then this
one we've still I'd like loved this one
a lot so their app engine calibrations
because it sounds cooler so they've
calibrated the App Engine alright okay
so why does this keep happening why is
it like every update is like oh god we
got to improve the performance we've got
to improve the performance right why is
this so hard like why didn't they get it
right the first time and it turns out
you know unlike bugs so okay so code is
always buggy right and you you know it's
hard to debug programs but it's like
this thing produce the wrong result
that's pretty clear but if you have
something and it just runs slower you
don't really know where or what to
change right so it can be really
complicated so what I'm going to talk
about are two things in this talk one is
performance analysis so I'm gonna
explain how to do performance analysis
right it turns out that the thing that
we including myself have often done it's
not really very rigorous and you can
draw the wrong conclusions and then I'm
going to talk about a new approach for
performance profiling that will show you
how to do it better all right so first
I'm going to talk about performance
analysis so here's Luke Luke has his
code and Luke is like it's too slow
hoggle is too slow what am I gonna do
and so Luke has an idea and Luke's idea
involves some sort of new you know I'm
going to do this first and I'm gonna
change this code I'm gonna change this
function blah blah blah I make a bunch
of changes right and eventually end up
with a prime all right the new version
of a and so now I want to know did it
work
right so I've made this change I thought
it would make things faster so I go and
I take my code and I have some set of
inputs some benchmarks let's say and I
go and I say run a and a takes 90
seconds which is clearly too long for
your app store thing to run but anyway
but notwithstanding that let's say
there's some thing that takes 90 seconds
in his tests right and then he runs a
prime eighty-seven point five seconds
fantastic success right two point eight
percent faster all right time for a
mojito okay so
this is great right and clearly you know
what Luke went did had a big impact big
impact all right the question is like is
it really faster right so if you go and
you plot like here's a bar graph with
I'm kind of giving away the game here
one execution of a prime in a it turns
out that a prime is 2.8 percent faster
looks good but there's maybe a problem
here so what's the problem right so
there's this problem called variance
right like when you run a program once
you're gonna get some result but if you
run it again maybe the result will be
slightly different and you want to
account for that great so now we'll run
it 30 times 30 is the magic number by
the way so we're gonna run 30 times and
we get this graph and so they're pretty
tightly distributed and you can see it's
still 2.8 percent faster
all right so seems plausible like I
think everybody here would probably be
like looks like a prime is faster great
so the question you have to ask yourself
is why is it faster so you might think
well of course the reason is the code
change right so I as Luke and the
developer and I go and I'm a genius and
I have my great idea and it pays off
2.8% right well it turns out changing
the code can actually lead to all sorts
of knock-on effects that have nothing to
do with your intended change so it could
totally be an accident so let me explain
why so there's this wonderful paper that
is it appeared in s boss in 2009 by Todd
Midwich and a number of other people I
highly recommend you read it it's
something like how to do things wrong
without really trying something like
that and the conclusion is that the
layout like we're the code and data end
up in memory has a pretty big impact on
performance alright so when you go to
measure something those measurements are
biased by depending where things kind of
fell right so here are a few things that
can have an impact on layout and I'm
going to talk about more so one is link
order so if you're in C C++ land and you
have a make file and the make file has a
bunch of this let's link step and has a
bunch of datos depending how those datos
are arranged you can get different
performance
okay do I think fine all right your
environment variables so when you go to
execute your program your environment
variables whether it's in C C++ or even
managed languages they somehow get
copied in and everything else gets
shifted so in C and C++ it moves this
moves the stack so this actually has an
effect on layout these two alone
can lead to shifts in performance of
plus or minus forty percent okay so
that's not great so what what is
happening like why is this happening
this is a huge shift this is literally
larger than the impact of - oh three / -
Oh zero okay yes you laugh but as well
you should
so why is a prime faster than a right so
what is going on why could this happen
without actually trying so part of the
problem here is that basically modern
processors have become insanely
complicated in their zeal to increase
speed so what do they do so they have
caches right and data and instructions
get mapped to the cache well it turns
out for good reasons
these things are binned up into these
things called sets they map to the same
set you can have a conflict so if you
have hot code a lot of hot code that is
mapping to the same set then it's not
going to necessarily fit in cache and
your code will run slower by luck you
could be in a situation where when you
changed a prime you actually disrupted
this conflict and so now you have no
conflict write it these two things one
is the hot code and one maps to nothing
so no conflict boom it ran faster all
right so that sounds great so it could
be the cache but it could also be the
branch predictor which actually again is
based on the addresses of your branches
and if these branches collide then you
can end up with things running slower
there's also this thing called the TLB
the translation lookaside buffer which
Maps virtual addresses to physical
addresses if things don't fit in the TLB
because they span two pages instead of
one suddenly things become slower
there's also a branch target predictor
there's a prefetcher there's more all
right so this is pretty bad so all of
these things can happen you might think
all right
Lync order is fine the code thing is a
little weird but you know hey it's
faster right it's 2.8 percent faster
that like I don't care it's all good
right now it may not be faster on every
machine but it's faster today right so
here's the problem like anything you do
can disrupt this so what could happen
one more malloc changes layout right
like you've shifted everything over one
more or less if you upgrade anything in
your system this is going to change
layout right so that's bad okay so those
things alright I'm not gonna change Lib
C and I guess I'll never malloc again
fine
whatever all right so here's something
that may be surprising running it in a
new directory so it turns out that your
current working directory goes right
into your your environment variables
right so that's weird right so you know
if Vader tries to run your software it's
not gonna work as fast because it's one
character longer than Luke okay this is
a real effect this can really happen it
is actually bitten me I had a student
who wrote some wrote something he has a
long Indian last name I my username is
just five letters long it's just Emery
and he did something he's like it
doesn't run any faster it actually runs
slower it was like that makes no sense
at all and eventually we were we
whittled it down and it was like if I
run it as me it's faster okay that's
right
all right changes your layout so the
solution is obvious right run everything
all right so so I should add you know
all of this is you know like the whole
talk is really oriented towards I'm
going to improve my performance but
everything I'm talking about today can
be viewed in Reverse for performance
regression like I made a change and
things run 2.8 percent slower Oh God
rollback maybe not right maybe the next
thing you do is going to actually undo
that change right so basically layout is
super brittle and like you've seen
layout biases measurement so one of the
questions that we want to know is is it
possible to eliminate the effective
layout so we can actually understand the
performance of things kind of without
having to think about well one malloc
less or more or you know Luke versus
Vader so the answer is yes we built a
tool that we call stabilizer so
stabilizer addresses this problem that
I've just explained to you pardon me
and it eliminates the effective layout
so this is the wet this is a way to
actually measure programs where you can
kind of actually know whether the
regression you had is real or whether
the optimization you had is real and not
just an accident
all right so how does this work how is
this even possible
so the way that stabilizer works is that
it randomizes layout so it randomizes a
lot of things it randomizes the function
addresses i randomizes stack frame sizes
it even randomizes heap allocations but
not only does it do those things it does
it over and over again right so while
your program is running
it's literally doing randomization and
this turns out to be important and I'll
show you a graph that will explain why
but basically if you do this then
there's no way layout can bias your
measurement because a completely random
layout can't bias the results right
that's just how things work that's why
we run randal randomized control trials
you've eliminated something as a
possible cause the only other cause that
remains is whatever change you made all
right
so let's walk through what you would do
with stabilizer so what stabilizer again
clearly you're supposed to run your
program a bunch of times but notice what
happens to the execution times here the
execution times are no longer tightly
bound around this this one very small
measurement the reason for that is that
when you were running that program 30
times it was sort of like you at you
were gonna do a survey of 30 people but
you just asked one person right because
it's the same layout over and over again
so you did an experiment on 30
executions but what you really did is
you just repeated 30 on one all right so
the only noise that you're eliminating
is the noise that comes from like
network demons waking up or some other
random event maybe some thermal issue in
your computer but it's not really
altering layout right it's always the
same layout so here it's not and you get
these very nice bell curves so now I'm
going to ask you the question so this is
an audience poll time is a prime faster
than a I just want you to raise your
hands if you think that a prime is
faster than a alright great now keep
your hands up don't send it down all
right okay but set them down well if you
change your mind how about now
okay how about now okay a lot of hits
still few like hardcore all right okay
so so what you all are doing is what I
like to refer to as eyeball statistics
and so your Cadillac looks close to me
that's too close right but it turns out
this is not actually a thing so if you
yeah it's not really Statistics when you
just eyeball results so this is a bit of
a refresher for some of you but I'm
going to walk you through this and how
this all fits in with stabiliser
so in actual statistics and today I'm
just going to talk about one flavor of
Statistics which is called null
hypothesis significance testing there
are others notably Bayesian approaches
happy to talk about that offline but
basically the way it works is you just
assume that the things are the same you
say what is the likelihood of observing
this difference by chance all right
so it turns out that this is this is
something that's just convenient it's
very easy to compute these probabilities
for the normal distribution which you
all remember from school these graphs
are normal awesome it turns out that
stabiliser happens to make normal graphs
or normal distributions and I'll explain
why so how are we going to do this we're
gonna run stuff with stabiliser
we're going to pick some probability
below which we're like okay good enough
right so if it's only a 1 in 20 chance I
see this probability like the day I see
this event occurring I'll be like okay
that's good enough for me you could be
harsher you could say one in a hundred
one in a thousand it's pretty standard
to say 1 in 20 this is the AP value of
0.05 so the idea is if there's a low
enough probability you reject the null
hypothesis the null hypothesis being
that they're the same and you conclude
that the speed-up is real it's not due
to the effective memory on memory layout
all right so why we randomization the
reason for reran demise ation is that
just randomizing once doesn't give you
enough randomization so this is an
actual program you can see the
distribution is pretty wacky it's very
far from normal
you can't intuitively explore much of
the space when you just randomized it
startup as opposed to randomizing during
execution this is in fact the kind of
distribution you get when you randomized
all the time and these are normal
distributions so why do I keep saying
that they're normal distributions
the reason is essentially again going
back to like freshmen stats stabilizer
generates a new random layout every half
second that is to say it's a completely
independent version of the program right
from half second to half second half
second it's all randomized and it's the
same program the whole time so it's
identically distributed and then we're
adding them all up and there's this nice
result key result of stats which is the
sum of a sufficient number so if you run
a program for long enough of independent
identically distributed random variables
it's approximately normally distributed
no matter what the underlying
distribution was this is the central
limit theorem alright so this makes
execution times normally distributed
which is cool in other ways because you
actually know how likely it is that
you're going to see some very weird
execution right because you know what
the distribution looks like alright
great so now we have this thing in hand
and we're gonna do something insane
we're going to see whether optimizations
are actually matter and we know some of
them matter all right so we have a suite
of benchmarks that we're going to
evaluate it on we're gonna evaluate them
individually and then across the whole
benchmark suite and I'll show you how we
do it so you build the benchmark so the
stabilizer stabilizer is a plug-in for
LVM if you just compile it as such it up
it goes and randomized does everything
but you can actually just randomize
things independently if you wanted like
just code just heap and just stack so
now we run the benchmarks we run them as
usual we drop them into one of my least
favorite programming languages ever and
and then we decide what the result is
all right so again we don't ask
questions like this because that's
eyeball stats right instead we ask a
question like this for 10 they were
equal how likely is it we'd observe this
much of a difference so I also have to
say that I'm not you know you should not
assume normality like almost ever in my
humble opinion unless you have very good
reasons for doing so here we have very
good reasons for doing so so we can use
really powerful statistical tests like
the students t-test so this is the test
that you use to actually measure this
difference so if the p-value is the
likelihood of this event occurring is
less than some thrush
which as I mentioned for is 5% we're
gonna reject the null hypothesis all
right that is to say it's not because of
random layout the difference is real
everybody's on board I hope so now we're
gonna do it you'll be shocked to learn
the - OH - versus - no one makes a
difference good
I'm would be weird if the result were
otherwise so you can see that there are
statistically significant improvements
right on the right there's some that are
statistically significant but don't
matter and by god they're statistically
significant performance drops so it
turns out that that compiler people run
these same benchmarks and overfit the
way that they do these optimizations and
some of them lead to layout changes and
it wasn't actually the code change and
so we can actually distill out this
effect
all right great by and large it looks
like Oh - over oh one is a win
how about ode three verses Oh - ready
it's amazing okay so I actually have to
change the axes so we can see a lot of
these values so I'm gonna zoom in
instead of it being zero - tattoo like
the range is negative 10 to 20 I'm gonna
make it zero to 1.5 okay so now we can
see them so they're pretty small effects
but some of them are significant and
some of them are not again statistically
significant 1.75 percent decrease in
execution time great a bunch of things
where it's not significant and a couple
decreases but really very minor effect
sizes so what do these results mean you
can't actually look at an individual
benchmark like there's 30 of them right
so drawing a conclusion about all 30 you
actually have to do something different
you have to collect all of them you get
a bunch of these graphs and this is what
you don't do like okay this one is
slower this one's faster this one's
faster this is just eyeballs everywhere
okay I mean they're spooky and nobody
wants to see those so again we're gonna
do the same thing but to test a bunch of
things simultaneously
you do this thing which is terribly
named called analysis of variance and
you plug it into our with this awesome
incantation and then you do again the
same
test if the p-value is less than or
equal to five percent we reject the null
hypothesis all right you ready all right
here we go here's the p-value so it has
to be less than or equal to 5% or else
we're going to conclude the - oh three
vs. - OH - is nothing all right so the
p-value is twenty six point four percent
that means that one in four experiments
will just show a random effect right
just literally randomly we do not
consider this enough evidence to reject
the null hypothesis so we're we cannot
reject the null hypothesis which is that
the effect is indistinguishable from
noise right okay so this is all terrible
news for people like Luke who wanted
optimizations to work and I've actually
seen I've actually seen projects it
makes it kind of breaks your heart like
projects I committed like on github
where it literally says - oh nine and I
feel like why not - oh 11 there's no
there's no - oh nine or 11 it's just
kind of bottoms out but you know hope
springs eternal all right so great so
what are we going to do so what people
do when they can't speed things up right
they run a profiler so there's these
profilers they all basically work the
same way you go and you get some result
and it says hey here's where my program
spent its time you get the number of
calls to every function run time for
each function and this captures
intuitively maybe for most of us like
this is what a profiler should do right
what's what do I care about there's
frequently executed code or code that
runs for a long time that's where I
should be focusing by optimization
efforts all right seems intuitively
appealing this is the way profilers have
been written since trough back you know
back from like I don't know late 60s
early 70s so would this in fact speed up
Gotham so we're gonna do this experiment
we're gonna go and find the thing that
runs for the longest amount of time and
where it spends all of its time running
and so we're going to run it and so we
go and we we do this and basically it
makes the loading thing flash faster
okay so well guess what that's
frequently executed and in fact
the code that runs for the longest time
right so this is not really great
especially if Luke spent like more than
a minute optimizing that code that's a
shame all right so basically in some
profilers were developed in an era where
everything was synchronous and there was
a single core all right
that's not today today things are
asynchronous or parallel or concurrent
or a mix thereof and profilers don't do
a good job in these contexts so we need
to do better so what would be really
cool is if we could have something like
this so this is what I call a causal
profile so a causal profile tells you
visually like if I were to speed up this
component by this much on the x-axis
then the whole program will speed up by
this much all right so this is really
nice like if I had this graph I would
know I could spend a little effort on
the yellow search component and I'll get
a big bang for my buck uh eventually
it's gonna bottom out are top out it
like you know like 70 80 % and the red
one I could just keep going right like
it gets faster and faster the more I
work and the blue one I should never
never optimize ever all right it would
be cool to know this right it's
essentially like an Oracle coming and
telling you this is the code you should
work on Luke I don't know where I got
that way of talking anyway
all right so the question is how would
we know this like how would we get this
information like how would we know that
this change would cause this effect
right we can't just go and optimize the
program by arbitrary amounts and test it
that kind of defeats the purpose so
we're going to do something different
we're gonna run an experiment and it
requires one ingredient here which which
I'll refer to as the force so we're
going to use magic and we're going to
speed things up magically and then we're
gonna measure how much the effect does
buzz of speeding up each component by a
certain amount on overall program
execution okay so we just keep doing
this right we get more and more points
right and then I do it for different
things it turns out if I could speed up
saving things to the three and a half
inch floppy it doesn't make a difference
right and so on all right now
unfortunately we live in the real world
where there's no magic sorry well if
there was magic to be clear this is not
what we would do right but I mean
obviously there are many much better
things we could do I could think of
people I would like to disappear off the
face of the earth for example but I
could also disappear all the runtime off
the face of the earth because why not
all right so obviously that's what we
would do so we can't do that we have to
do something else so what we are going
to do as our trick is we're going to do
something that essentially takes
advantage of this notion of relativity
so we're going to do a virtual speed-up
and a virtual speed-up speeds things up
in scare quotes by slowing everything
else down all right so everything else
that's running at the same time will
then be slowed down and that will allow
us to get the impact of how do we sped
this thing up what would the results
have been all right so here for example
if we speed up the sending of the the
the picture results back by a certain
amount we've slowed down everything
running concurrently with it and then
that gives us a result of a slowdown
which is the same thing as the result of
having sped it up all right so we
actually can get points on this graph
just by running these experiments right
so I just got a point here and I do it
for everything and I get more points
right and eventually I get a graph like
this if I speed up indexing when you get
the exact same effect right indexing is
running at the same time as the
compression right so I've get this
result and then bang I get these results
and again these are like all the results
right now I draw your attention to the
one weird blue thing so the blue thing
is slower right and it turns out that
sometimes optimizing things makes your
program run slower and the intuition
behind this is you can actually get
congestion on a lock right or congestion
for a shared resource like disk or
network and so speeding things up makes
things worse you would like to know this
before you get started right that would
be a very very bad day for Luke that
might necessitate several sequels to
recover from all right great all right
so let's let's dig in to audit all right
so what do we care about a novel
care about two things we care about how
long it takes between a request and a
response right
aka latency traditional profilers don't
do this at all right that's just total
run time oh let me get on my soapbox for
one moment
traditional profilers are about
end-to-end run time you know how your
servers are all about end-to-end run
time or your browser like if only your
browser could quit faster right so again
like it was all about like here's the
program I run it a console and it does
something and it's done and that's all I
cared about that's not really today all
right so there's latency and then the
more traditional thing is throughput
again this is something that profilers
do a bad job of measuring because
they're all about end-to-end execution
time right so how fast results come back
is throughput right so how are we going
to do this so with our causal profiler
that I'm going to explain in a minute
we're going to introduce what we call
progress points so the notion of
progress points is here's the thing I
want to happen faster or here's a
beginning and an end of things that I
want to happen faster
all right so if Luke wants responses to
get sent faster higher throughput you
just mark this particular start of this
component as a progress point and every
time the code runs you go and you get
another coin all right and then you can
do this simultaneously many requests for
many users right and all of these things
are incrementing some counter so these
progress points are measuring throughput
and then you basically are going to run
the experiments and see what the effect
is on the rate of those progress points
being executed all right so one point
measures throughput like I said if I
speed up some component whatever it
might be what is the effect all right so
now what if I care about latency so we
do the exact same thing we said a
progress point at the beginning a
progress point at the end and then the
only thing that has to happen under the
covers is it has to have a counter on
the counter here measures how many
things are in the system at any one time
and it turns out that there is this
awesome law that holds in a wide variety
of circumstances called littles law and
so littles law says that the latency is
essentially the number the average
number of transactions in
system divided by the throughput we
already know how to measure a throughput
so we just take advantage of littles law
and we can translate this into latency
right great so we have built a causal
profiler for Linux it already ships with
Debian and Ubuntu so if you're using one
of those systems you can install it
quite easily so it's just cause -
profiler it's quite easy to run so you
say cause run - - and whatever your
program is and its arguments and it
fires it off and it starts doing
performance experiments all right
I should add it's not entirely true you
do need to place progress points if you
don't place any progress points it will
act like an ordinary profiler measuring
end to end execution time but if you do
put in progress points then it will
actually do its magic all right and this
is just some macro like prog progress
begin progress end all right so let's
apply this to ogle alright I didn't
actually build ah --gel neither did Luke
but we're going to build it out of
pieces like any good programmer would do
so it turns out there's this suite of
parallel applications that's kind of
ready-made for this task
so there's ad duplicator that does
compression there's an image comparator
and then there's a database sequel light
that's not in parsec but we'll use
sequel light - all right great so I'm
going to show you some fun things we did
this is a well-studied
set of applications people have already
tried to optimize these and we have
covered a bunch of surprising
optimization opportunities
so here's ferret this is actually an
older version of what our console
profile looks like now it runs in a web
browser and you can see that there's
these lines of code and it says boy if
you speed up these lines of code then
you're going to get performance
increases conveniently these lines of
code happen to be located in separate
chunks of ferret so the part that does
ranking the part that does indexing in
the part that does segmentation and why
is this convenient it's the I'm not
gonna have to change any code to make
this faster the reason is that what
ferret does is it has this pipeline
model and it assigns an equal number of
threads to every stage in the pipeline
but it turns out this one really doesn't
need that many threads so we take away
the threads and just by reassigning
threads we got a 20
percent speed-up okay so so this is
pretty cool
because cause actually predicted it
perfectly so we increased ranking for
example from 16 to 22 threads that's a
twenty seven a percent increase in
throughput and on the graph that says
that that would translate to a twenty
one percent overall improvement and
that's what we got
alright so the cause actually works good
so we were pretty happy with this we
then are going to move on to 2d doop
so dee doop is pretty hilarious so so
here's dee doop in action i have two
pictures
grumpy cat juan and grumpy cat meme
alright and so now what do i do to
deduplicate these things you can see
that there's chunks that are the same so
you carve out the chunks that are the
same and you separate them out into
individual pieces and then an image is
now represented by the bits and pieces
that make up the image so here a grumpy
cat one is this piece and fun is awful
is this piece and you saved a lot of
memory all right so that's what Dee Duke
does so it does this compression via
deduplication and it uses a hash
function right so it throws everything
to a hash data great so it's a pretty
standard hash table you just have some
hash table it's an array it's a bunch of
bins you get a bin number and then you
go and you start adding stuff to that
bin okay into the bucket so this all
seems straightforward you hope that it
would do something like this the hash
table is accessed concurrently by a
bunch of threads but they're not idiots
there's not one big lock it's just all
locks which is naive but it's fine but
surprisingly cause says that the loop
that accesses this list is important now
if you know anything about hash tables
you know that things generally end up
balanced right and it's weird that you
have this sort of situation so we
thought all right well let's just make
more more hash buckets right but we made
a thousand of them we really should have
made a million because you know a
million but anyway
so you would think this would lead to
fewer collisions but it had no effect
alright so what else could be causing
the collisions any guesses the hash
function exactly like this is one of
those when all other possibilities have
been exhausted right you pick the
weirdest one that's not accident exact
quote but anyway well you're like how
can the hash function be broken like
we've been using hash functions since
before Knuth wrote about them well turns
out people like to roll their own
because it's fun and so we did a
histogram of the number of items per
bucket so again I told you there's a
thousand buckets this is the histogram
yeah hilariously what they did is they
use the pixels that were taken from the
the image and they have a some number of
pixels then added them but that's
actually the central limit theorem in
action right they're random right there
are independent right and you've summed
them together and so they actually form
the normal distribution that's not the
distribution you want for a hash table
you would like a uniform distribution so
literally we changed one character we
changed the plus two X or so this and we
got this okay
so so okay I'll take the applause but I
mean it was only a 9% speed-up but all
right nonetheless it was one character
so I think it's the biggest bang for
buck ever recorded in optimization
effort so so what did it predict it
turned out we can also measure the
accuracy the prediction so we knew that
the blocks per bucket went from 76 ish
to - that's a 96% traversal speed-up and
again going back to the causal graph it
predicted a 9% speed-up which is what we
got all right so it's working all right
so finally I'm going to talk about
sequel light so I have no time left but
sequel Lite is pretty awesome it's
widely used as you all know but it has
this weird thing where it has a kind of
strange like a virtual table that they
set up at compile time and so whenever
you you actually indirect through a
config to execute a function like
pthread mutex on lock so you would think
all right why are you telling me about
this well everything looks like this
this is an indirect call could be a
direct call that would be faster but I
mean an indirect call is not that slow
but it's almost the same cost as pthread
mutex unlock which means that you just
doubled the length of all of your
critical sections so that's not great so
in fact when you go so cos will
highlight all of these lines and say you
should definitely optimize these so we
undid all of the all of the actual like
indirect stuff and just made it so that
at compile time you changed sequel Lite
unlock to something so it doesn't do the
indirect and it sped things up by 25%
okay I if you look at a traditional
profiler by the way those things are
like this takes point ooo one percent of
time right you would never consider
actually trying to optimize that code so
we did it for a bunch of programs we got
some crazy speed ups my favorite is we
got a 68% speed up by replacing a custom
barrier with a standard barrier again
people should stop doing things at home
some
so anyway so I'm going to conclude so
you can take a picture of this to jump
to work from our lab which is plasma
UMass org I talk today about sound
performance analysis and effective
performance profiling everybody should
go use the cause alright thanks for your
attention
[Applause]